cada una de estas barras que tenemos
aquí tiene 10 bloques contemos entonces
uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete
ocho nueve diez y tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho barras
entonces bueno como cada barra tiene
diez bloques tenemos ocho decenas a cada
barra la podemos ver como una decena
tenemos ocho decenas y tenemos tres
bloques aquí ahora cada bloque
representa una unidad como tenemos tres
entonces tenemos tres unidades
tenemos tres unidades las ocho decenas
la tenemos aquí con este ocho representa
ocho decenas y el tres representa a las
tres unidades o los tres bloques ahora
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
restarle al número 83 algo digamos que
le vamos a restar 25 a 83 entonces le
queremos restar 25 a 83 y lo que quieres
hacer es bueno observa primero el lugar
de las unidades yo tengo tres unidades y
quiero restarle cinco unidades entonces
te preguntarás cómo hago eso como como
hago eso como le quito 5 a 3 como le
puedo quitar 5 cosas a algo que sólo
tiene 3 cosas lo que podemos hacer es
tomar una de estas decenas y separarla
de esa manera convertimos esa decena en
10 unidades entonces tomamos esta barra
y la vamos a separar vamos a separar
todos sus bloques entonces tendremos 13
unidades bueno para explicarme un poco
más voy a dibujar aquí esas esa barra
como si lo hubiera separado ya entonces
tengo debo tener 10 unidades ahí van 45
78 si son mucho a ver 12345678 así
faltan 29 y 10 entonces ya tenemos ahí
tomé tome una decena y las separe en
unidades tenemos 10 unidades entonces
recuerda lo que hice fue de estas ocho
decenas yo quite esta decena pero no la
desaparecen no no no esto no es magia
eso lo pasé a las unidades ya no tengo
ocho decenas tengo ahora siete decenas
porque esa decena la pasé a las unidades
como puedes ver la sume a las unidades
entonces no tenemos tres unidades
tenemos 13 unidades
13 unidades y ahora si podemos ahora es
más fácil restar si yo tengo 13 unidades
y le quiero quitar 5 unidades
entonces bueno lo que voy a hacer es
quitarle vamos a vamos a quitarle cada
cinco bloques aquí 1 2 3 4 5 esos son 5
bloques que representa cada uno una
unidad entonces a 13 unidades le
quitamos 5 unidades
me quedan 8 unidades que son exactamente
estas 8 unidades que tengo aquí ahora
vamos al lugar de las decenas vamos a
quitar dos decenas de esas siete decenas
que tenemos ajá entonces vamos a quitar
vamos a quitar esta decena
esa es una decena vamos a quitar la
segunda decena
ahí es siete decenas menos dos decenas
me van a quedar tres cuatro cinco
decenas que van a quedar estas cinco
decenas y es exactamente lo mismo aquí
72 es igual a 5 ahí lo tienes 83 menos
25 es igual a 58 lo que hicimos se llama
reagrupar tomé un grupo de 10 los separe
en 10 unidades para poder estar en el
lugar de las unidades
entonces ese 3 se convirtió en 13 porque
a 13 unidades le sume 10 unidades y tome
esa esa decena la toma del lugar de las
decenas entonces bueno eso fue lo que
hice lo puedo escribir de esta manera
para que se entienda para que quede un
poco más claro entonces bueno 83
es lo mismo que 80 383 es igual a 83 y
25 es lo mismo que 20 más 5 pero como
estamos restando 25 entonces cambiamos
los signos
restamos 20 y restamos 5 eso es lo mismo
que restar 25 35 el 5 es mayor que el 3
entonces pido prestado del 80 10 y me
quedan 70 esos 10 que pedir prestados se
los pongo al 3 se lo sumo entonces tengo
13 y 13 menos 5 eso es igual a 8 ahí ya
puedo restar ahora vamos con las decenas
70 menos 20 eso es igual a 50 y 50 más 8
es igual a que a 58 entonces tenemos
exactamente el mismo resultado